they hate that one God is great baby
straight new album is out new album is
out absolutely
uh how is everything man you are wrapped
up in a lot of [__] there's a lot of
back and forth on the internet right now
I just saw my son just dropped a new
record today did you see that no I don't
I don't I don't end insane
like
trash you feel me like when we don't
stop to pick the coins up off the floor
it don't make no sense it's like really
trash I'm
I can honestly see how I go the rest of
my life without
hearing a song from a taxi robber you
feel me you put a record out about him
though right yeah he's no I I just
talked about him being a taxi robber
when I make records this is a facts I
actually Rob taxi drivers and he stole a
hundred and three dollars in total uh
walkie-talkie and a gold ring and he did
seven years in jail for that so I
wouldn't listen to the music of somebody
whose life is worth 15 a year it made no
sense and I suggest you don't either so
you don't even unless you just like
consume and Chase so if somebody disses
you you're not even like let me just
take a listen well I never like what the
[__] am I listening to for I don't
oh I'm not like one of these when I tell
you the type of music I listen to I
listen to Soul music I listen to Tupac I
listen to
um
pz like it's different I don't just be
listening to rap just listen to rap
around I don't give a [__] about that
I'd rather when I sit in my pool in my
house I'm listening to [__] you know
put 80s dance hits on like Scarface
I just if someone if someone put a whole
song to get together about me I'm at
least listening to it once I can't
listen to it because there's no there's
nothing they can do
I don't have no skeletons in my closet
can't nobody pull nothing like I'm I'm
super authentic not to say that like so
God whatever I'm just saying like
authentic as [__] is probably living in
my truth so something that somebody's
gonna say is nothing that you can come
out and say to discredit me this person
did this to me before like how somebody
could say Chino got wedgied and cut by
boxing bar and oh now it's a big thing
or might sound you a taxi ride but you
try to get it straight from the incident
now your activists know you're a taxi
robber and a hater you know what I'm
saying so what are they gonna say about
your ass I'm a successful businessman I
own Lamborghinis and other phones I got
13 properties like I own uh trucking
companies I mean I got a restaurant
businesses like what are you gonna say
about me I don't have a whole baby moms
like what's what's the [__] you gonna
put unless you're gonna make up some
[__] like or have an opinion that most
people don't share so what the [__] am I
there's never gonna be no shocking [__]
that they gonna say about me that I
don't know about myself and it's not
offensive they're gonna try to make
something up and use it in an offensive
way I don't consume [__] bro I don't
eat junk food well I think like um a
couple of things to clear up because I
do think that now that obviously
the trial and you know everything is
passed you could you could speak for the
most part for the most part I gotta go
to jail for no [__] I ain't gonna say
for no [__] reason but
let's see It'll be up to the judge
maybe a year maybe longer maybe maybe
less maybe the judge would be like you
know you ain't been in no trouble before
this or after this so you know you it
was an isolated incident a jealous
bottom feeder predicate felon bum ass
[__] hater that you know [__]
gasoline on the fire so well I think um
because kind of helped me walk me
through this because
taxton's lawyer his name is rat Stone we
address people probably
listen the guy's in jail you won he's in
jail it doesn't matter well
it ain't no you know what I'm saying
like so it's levels it's levels to
winning and [__] you feel sure I had
lost custody in my kids I had to fight
for that I had to pay over 200 000 loyal
fees
yes all of these type of [__] that I had
to go through my career was crippled
right like it ain't you can't you can't
I'm I'm kicking a [__] scumbag
cockroaches when they down you feel me
I'm stepping them it's gonna be guts on
the bottom of my shoe his name is
redstone he wrote a letter to the judge
and his whole defense was that he didn't
kill Banger Troy Ave did it wrestled for
the gun and Troy shot his friend so he's
a [__] rat and he's a [__]
cockroach and he's a bottom feeder and
we need to remove haters from the
[__] Community we need to remove them
they need to be treated with the same
disdain as we do [__] snitches that
do crowns with their homies and turn
around and flip on them as we do it
child molesters as we do with rapists
all these type of people because haters
are cancer and that [__] spews over to
other people well that's what I was
gonna say so I've this you know I think
that the one thing about this gentleman
is he does have a lot of Industry
friends right and so me being somebody
who was actually friends with Banga
right I think I had a lot of love for
you
um
I never was like
free dude [__] that like dude killed my
boy you know what I'm saying like I
personally like it is what it is I'm not
in the situation I wasn't there but like
um I think that the the I do think that
the reason why you're not necessarily
going
through a lot of the backlash that like
um maybe a guy like six nine went
through is because the situation
at least how it's been explained is
you just cleared your name up after a
lawyer essentially wrote a letter
pinning everything on you well it wasn't
so much a lawyer it was so much him you
can't do anything without your lawyer's
approval you have to give your latest
information his lawyers is not coming up
with alleged crimes that we was involved
in that's him being a goddess in the
know of Street things you know what I'm
saying it's not his lawyer is not coming
up with this info so they wrote a letter
to the judge but even before that the
whole defense was that you know I
shooting on camera right you know what
I'm saying like just just Coney [__]
that we not going for and as far as like
me and six nine is totally different
because
six nine is it it was an active gang
member when you win gang [__] that [__]
is in the streets you keep that [__] in
the streets I don't care if somebody
rapes your mother you go kill them oh
you have whatever happens to them right
you it don't be no police [__] involved
oh my street business I kept in the
streets I got shot when I was 15. never
heard about it it's in the streets I
barely don't even rap about it right I
got shot in my head on Christmas Day
yeah I was there the detectives was at
my best side I ain't have nothing to say
because we kept that in the streets this
[__] is the internet this [__] is the
same thing that with this is like a
stalker somebody who would tweet
somebody 780 times over a five-year
period this is craziness it's like the
person who killed John Lennon the the
[__] who killed Selena even though she
wasn't a stalker she was an assistant
right like this is a totally different
situation you feel me this started in
the public and you don't never allow
nobody to just say I'ma crash out throw
my life away and I'm taking you down
down with me now get the [__] over me
you go off that bridge yourself don't
yeah get off my body right right right
right right and I do think too like you
know you said letter aside that it was a
situation that was but I do think the
letter kind of like at least optically
kind of like is like hey
definitely you know what I mean like you
want me to just like go with what this
letter says you want me to hold myself
down you feel me yeah you wanna you
wanna play it fair you wanna you wanna
play fit and inside that you know I
would even let somebody determine the
Rules of Engagement rules of the game
you know what I'm saying which it
happened but then it's like wait hold on
this we both in the ring box and this
person took the gloves off and you know
I mean they they spray some [__] in my
eyes the [__] I'm supposed to do I
wanted to talk to you because
um and the real ones are seeing that if
you look at the public opinion even with
people like my son is generally these
nuts the taxi robber he'll put up a post
and people will be under his comments
like [__] you talking about I have a
real [__] he bugging he did what most
rappers talk about doing you want him to
take the murder of his friend you want
to take attempted murder on somebody
that shot him and he took the gun from